welcome everyone to that I DPS
you have questions if you do have
questions you welcome to you and ask
Harderwijk please use chapter room to
position of Pleasant so There We Can I
rest stand increenius Asian atient
second Today's
ddclassy discussion is allowed so please
What Shout
finally the talk Today will be recorded
and up loading in our YouTube channel
Alright means with used Towers speaker
Today It Is An Honor to Horse to
Benjamin Sanders Who is leading the
Scenic computing Group at SEW
National Institute for mathem computer
Science I'm wet heat Group GTA and
algorithms that Focus on I know a
Models Which unbind Physical modeling
and data driven a Technics you Walk that
the intersection of many The
plinting on 13 cuatification pd's and
discussion methods
Main on Coin Them In Heat rockies to
laborate a Physical structure uh
suchades in barriants and conservation
los in designing new
outlet onsenders optim The Heat PS tdgree
in 2013 kung Loud from erm a lot and
University  of Technology after a Future
he walks the at the  Research for a
Furious in Industrial have to complete
a ten Year track at sewi in 2001 habi
came Research Group leader in 2022 hits
eat he's condition to
The Pleasure to speaker Origins so eh
well introduction I think already status
All so I don't know going to repeat that
uh I do want to a Knowledge uh some of
the people in in my Group eh PG seated
sever Toby Hendrik and Hugo this is the Lot of
the work pay present Today er and I
also want to start uh with giving a bit
of an introduction uh intense
not everyone notes to Institute And then
What I Hope for this Presentation is
that uhm dit at the end Jewel Have a
good Idea About The Titan Loft of the
Slide Fight so There 3 Elements One is
structure pre serving The Other One is
and bad it and then There discreet lodge
model of something I try to highlight East 3
Parts duning is presentation What First
Let's eh Talk About ehm do
n't you see that
Okay
computer Science so We Are Independent
In The  Sand That We are not belonging
directly to your
really Research  institude to we don't
have direct DJ assignment but we Focus to on
the Research That's much as possible be
your Found The Just after the second
rottwar with the Idea to boost uh
Research and Martin computer Sight in
the Netherlands in Amsterdam so We are
really on the nice Side Close To The
City
and The Mission is It's about doing
Research in love and computer Sight of
course but uh publishing it in in
leading journals but also to bring it to
Society and to Industries so we try to
make the Link To The  Practical
applications is and
the Bit of defect are videos about
Around to and the People
divided into 15 Research groups one of
them Of course
The More That's The computer Science
Orient At Once the like cryptobwoofy eh
and security and things like that Cyrus
Security
Guido Van Rossum eh Back In The Days and
kind of hobby project ehm and Still we
have severi Roll spin of Company that
results into a company
so The Scientific computing Group eh The
Good that I'm Heading I see it is
combini Elements in Olde work That We Do
so that is machine Learning Unity
quantifications and what we want to do
is predictive Science so offen we have
some Physics model that is given by the
differential equation in order to make it
workable and really predictive release
to add unsernity quantification methits
to that and
a tip I use new machine Learning
to speed up things so
in this way this Combination Yes the
kind of our Toolbox to address All Kind
of problems can be from difference
and the my team is that we try to design
new Q or new machine Learning mathis by
using  The nollies That We have from the
physics rolls and this is when we devise the
concept of stripped pre serving
to later and Dender Different topic
so in the introduction SO closure model
with the topic of today stalk also rejuust
order mods
talk about today but We Do a lot of work
on that as well eh base invert problems
and of course nuorel Networks you can not
Go Around That Now that is so
Let Me continue with close Models that
topic for today
and They appear in the white righty of
applications so The application That We
Are typically interested in coming
from Energy and  climate eh problems so
from zampel in the middle you see wakes
in the official wind farm and this came
challenges on How to design uh your Wind
Farm and Osse How to control The turbine
state that is Awake influence is
mitigate is much is possible and of
course also questions about uh How to
resolve eh clouds a small it Models
rhythmoddels what you typically to
expensive but it's very important en
Osso This is a problem of slushing of
lick of Fight gas When It's
in large  tankers
so Where does the Closer Problem coming
to play on What is the closure Problem
well in Fluid Flows we typically have
many skills Of Motion So if you go back
to this winst Farm case than we skills
are round Tan kilometer If You Zoom in
to a tipical winterbind late Thank you
account is skills of Maybe Around The
meter And The Ready Sea eh you see som
Different Type of eh skills in terms of
the Wake Up The [ __ ] from the twins
Edge Of The deblade and then you have Zoom
on Inverter than you expc de  turburn
Found relader to stay and to the
Skill or take your millimeter even narrower
so simulating all the skills is
definitely unfaceable with the
competition of model and I want to remain
like this for manue Years
in the Caribbean and then yes Dead of course
consist Again of clouds and if you want
to know what happens Here do you don't
want to result Every single Cloud
Because It's Too expansive and erm yes in
this case is Maybe not Cold Closer
modeling eh but it's the party code per
metrization and if there is an order Field eh
the close modeling Problem Is Cold  some
time scores graining or eh
Closer problems
Okay start
of Closer and to user ver is simple
equation
Which is eh
Attraction diffusion Type Of The quation
ehm and that it in Osso this solution to
Disney Creation is she get small skills
if you have a small value for the
Discovery
the Idea Is Now that you don't want to go
to
result
s
to timestamping that it going to give me
a good solution on discord
solution you the next time step is Just
going to be given by eh kind of oiler
timestamping  With The Train to roll
Network that  could Do This And effect
When you look at the results is in
doesn't look to bad so in in blue There
is the Sword of the exact Fine Bridge
solution And then In Red There's The
Train Canal Network solution so we
traineral Network offline and then this eh
included in this time Stepping to soft
the solution That is a look to bed but
it's extreme not Heart To Do better
so Well this is the Idea of ​​pre serving
structure so in the previews xable here this
this equation where you say The Can
you see my pointer By the way you  find
me with
Yes okay here this include Dennis Any
Knowledge really About This
pdi Ride So yes There is confection
diffusion It's All in Divergent form er
his own continuous so that style of
facts recruit extreme include When we
want to learn The model so first we
have the what we called the no closure
model and Which We Just solved the
equation on a coursecript so We Don't
include Any editional effect that shoot
corrector solution recal this the low
resolution model the no close model and
we get an error of Point One Okay  I'm
skipping that definition of the Arrow It
is not  so important for the point Here
and Lenders the Basic machine Learning
model that I just show before and it's
again The Big Better so That's nice
The error Drops By Now the Factor then and
That We Can Take A number step and
Say Hey actually If We Do ehm do Right
out the derration of this eh eh
discord-grip model it Should Be of this
for met should be the original eh
equations eh the container convection and
diffusion plus sum correction term
bit recorder closure model and if you
a soon this form and  you train The near
of Network for this Again you find The
Drop in Arrow so we didn't really Do
Anything Advanced with the new orle
Network We Just eh learn Different forms
eh we learnia definition Question form And
then There is Another step That You
Could taken Say Hey actually we know
that is equation is preserving Momentum
so We ride eh We Don't include the world
Network directly but We ride the
Divergent of some neural Network eh for
difference in Disguise And then you see
a lotter small eh Drop in the Arrow
This is  good news Right So you can
already but  Just Changing the way you
formulator equation
Network you can re juice The Arrow
and Maybe important Point this that This
Is A special use for if you have small
near on Nether Works
Sense of course because Networks You Can
Make Me lyrics for small 0 Network sits
Face Off to include Knowledge of the
Physics Oh the structure of your
quation
Okay so That's going to be eh the main part
of today stalk How to preserve structure
inclosure Models and to attanks Ability
and then um I will alaborate for what he
Just shows  There is Another part of the
talk and Defense does there much time
there is but then I want to say a bit
about eh How to Train such modelz and
There private two Different
approaches with you called the riverdive
fitting and The Other want projectory
fitting
and then the overarching three teams
have loede there then beginning discotis
First presseur structure and anbedded
Learning Will Come Back All The Time
during discog Zo dit comes Clear that
means
Okay This Is Going what I'm going to Skip
Today so  You're Do you know that so
That's For The Future so  First a bit
Basics of closure modeling zo Let's Go
Back To The Basics so we consider PD eas
that discribe many skills that is bit
morphonement Medical setting Now so Time
Evolution vd-eas en
tendency This is F of you can for op will b
eh convection diffusion pressure
gradant like an Event stokes and They
describe 2 many skills Of Motion when
you have a small vistosity prematar and
in this case so we have a single pdi
that discripes all the skills so has
multi Skill problems  really have
multiple's for Different skills but not
be stoke We Just Look at the single
equation that describes all skills and
we try to re juice the Range of skills
by filtering so We Are soon There so sum
vul-filter turn off filter in Disguise
with curnal G and There we define is
filter ehm the filter eh redeem TS eh
Flying so eh that's a lot of Team Operation
to redeem and then when you
filter your equation then you come up
with the
pdi for the filterpump which is That's  The
Challenge Right  and what do you want what do
you want yes In The End we want to
have a question Mash and large att Times
The Only solveig For The filter
lighting
so the artist to find the closure model
that approximate the social committator
error so the commentator error is the
arrow that is eh yes that the Rises
Because The uh filtering operations and
the the Yes the
pdi operator They Don't commute and Tim
particular information stokes this will
be you to the longenarity of the
confective Terms so filtering and eh the
London
decoratdicterm in stokes you Creations
Day do not commute but you Can have
Order sources of comitator aeros for
Jump Poland eh does the track wheel comes is
etcor non-uniform filters
and so Disclosure model ideas to
developmodel just as a function of or the
filterd redeem t-ride that costs just
like the thing that you want to solve
erm and Finding that is definitely en
annivers Problem and it Can have many
wild The possu Illusion in zit cab
ilpost that Center So this is the
difficult thing and you can excel Think
May  be This is
eh in Possible to do Right you don't have to
marry we have a lot of information all
your small skills there True No Way and you
Kwai to Still eh that dance material for the
small playful what you Still try to
understand what is the effect of the
small skills on to the large skills
the filtert velocity
filter variable
and in the picture Yes You Could Write it
like this So if we go to in
a discreet setting you it have a Fine
Grid solution and you are the
approximated by course with flesh som
editional correction not really very
Metal medicaly Sound that Sometimes this
confeest much More Than all the equation
zo and traditional lead is Closer model
is formulated in a continuous setting
and then People use for eksempel
for the double turbulent discosity and
the fiscalcity Greetings nice but
Because Of The interpretibility but it
is raw The difficult to have Universal
Epic ability
would be the alternative route That We Are
Looking At is to go to discreet setting
and Use the Networks and make Them
trailer made to the Problem and this is
Closer model csav function Of You bar is
a complex London map  and close the modelz
are definitely good candidates for that
uh  nu al Networks are definity good
canadache for that Okay so
in pictures It Looks The but like
this so We Do have a pdi for all skills
Which continuous level we filter Dead so
we do is the complexity pdi Just For The
large skills plus close and model And
then in the Classic commodor
projes to Follow can distribute so First
continuous and then you discotis what You
Could do in stats what we do is you say
Okay First discotis all the skills so I
Still have All skills in my system large
Kill small skills eh  so I get the
summituspreat System eh like this the
Unity is apple views and so to the
discotized f and then I rejuice The
complexity Which results in a filtering around the
discrete system and then I get the street
closure model in Audition On The Right
And site Why would you want to do that will
the One Thing is that you get
consistency between a training date I
That's The Weatherly generated Here and
joper dictionarirement Which is again er
the infer's Problem that you still have to
solve to  get Disclosure model is
Innocence easier under  descreet level eh?
So you can think about the Technique
Sauce truecated single of Valley
compensations and such that that is the way
to
regularis and that is
eacher on the discrete level
also erm yes the close model that is Taylor
made to your discotisation because you
are red on the discrete level and There's
a modern Maybe More technical eh things
related to regularity and to job
reconditions
and that other thing that We Do So be
size discotis first we try to pressure
so  That's What I Started With The
Burgers equation so We Can Say Hey
giants odi formulation Oh sorry this is
ehm even or YouTube
is the right Inside plus
Because We Know IP The has this property
and USA convolution 0 Network
Architecture Which has this Translation
property Translation inferance property
So This is what I'm ready Shout for
Burgers To Hell which is properties and then
visional property that I want to talk
about today is Energy conservation Which
is the Great way to eh to get stability
so ehm
If You just
Network to my pdi and I  train It then we
typically
Getting to this model data  inconsystem
Because you ehm your train The Little
Network offline than you plukket into
your pdi and dance Surprise you get
instabilities And that can be Because
you know Network Goes outside of Barrett
was trained during and Actual Time
dependence simulation ehm or cambi due
to discotisation issues but This Is
Common issue model date in consistency
and instabilities of your use a little
Networks to rapper centralow model and
There couple of process that try to
dachshund this also they pop up at using
Artificial noise at a  eh with less
Maartje backsketter for a small
skills to large skills eh with the
projection eh or the 0 network Contour
Stable Days is like Eddy versconcerty
bases and
Different Way Looking At The Problem is
dead of doing supervis Learning using
Green forcement learning
so Our proaches is Slightly Different
Because I Said we try to use Energy
conservation to gange please tability and
So What is this Idea well many pdis
inclusive not your stokes eh deprocess
secondary conservation eh like Energy or
entropy and who is poison is Ability mount
would you If You  Look at Have You stokes
inkompressible So You have Dark Virgins
of us
and if you be fine your connectic Energy
like this
then you can quickly Drive that the
changing for periodic conditions s
Always Negative so connectic energies
Always decreasing In Time
In it's you to fiskes disappasion it
would be Possible
and then you get the discrete Energy eh
Balance and stability Bound and Now Power
ideas to also used this Type of
structure for the filter decuations
Ah This is not trivial Because if you
filter than you do not  have this
property Animal for the filtered
quantity's right So This holds for the
original
philosophy Field but It Doesn't Hold for
the filter loses that much So this is
the Challenge comeback to that later
He does not want to go to have your strokes
Today but I will show you the Korteweg
de Vries equation what you sometimes have Simple
properties you have stokes It's
destructure water and he Solid Tom is
Solutions and it Looks Like This so that
they Osso producting of linearity and then
There is a Third order term eh Just eh
Call this  person Waves
and this has the similar Energy
conservation poppers and  this is a
secondary eh
conservation
Lords multiplying Dizzy Question by you
integrating enten
yes then get that the time The
Riverdale Energy is Zero
Zoom the right your seats on Solutions
grabbelt Solutions of the citizens
equations and we dispatized The System
using excuse and Metric Skin And then you
get this semi discrete system and you get
the properties are these brackets are is
an in product you get that also The
biscuit solution satisfies and Energy
Quality or something that is fun
Let's great
So Far we Didn't  Do anyfilter Be The
Next One and what I said this we
discotis First so we have this week
system already Here Still descript All
skills
small skills And then we proposed
spaceful Just going to be a Matrix and
It can be filter that you like
tophead filter Something Else but Ready
and the so we have magically to gridge
define Grid with all skills And The
Course Grid with the Only The Yes the
large skills and w eh Maps from the small
skills to the large skills well if you
have this mapping Double This Is Matrix
this filter double  you you can also
define reconstruction operator Which
does the other The  Other Way Around So
You reconstructure solution net your
course Grid RT your fine with from your
de solution Edge of course Grid eh and
This Is difficult to Construct arm
because There All Kind of Choice As you
can make but Take for example woman that
Simply polon gates of solution here to
this Point dispoint and dispoint and
That's the next reviews erm and
yes There requirements on that but
I'm not going to die to Here but if you
have reconstruction operator are then
you can also define
new Dash as the difference of eh The
Original solution  you and uh what you
get when you reconstruct the filterd
solution So This is the definition
and How Does that look like for this
Korteweg de Vries ecuation wow
the solution in blue you see the subwit
content eh in green new Prime And then
The reconstructive solution In Red and
that's Because of this
Evolution
of the Total Energy is Just give away
Energy and the bank
the Total Energy increasingly extractly
constants the Blue Line And then The
Change In eh the cosco energy's exactly
the Negative of What happens to the
fine skills
What is wanted to use the style of Energy
stability we think  need information about
the small skills and When results Only
For The large kills We all the Get You
bar so we don't know you you Dash So if
you want to use Energy stability and we
want to use expression we need to say
s  omething about you Prime
and this picture also clearly shows that
the large Kill Energy is not preserved
Quantum Right oil the Total Energy ze
concert
Okay so what do I do Simulator you
Prime is not feasible so instead replace
It by a socle compressed course Grid
fairybal s and
When You Take an in a product so When you
look at the Energy of As it is
proximitly ecod to the eh Energy of the
eh de subs skills and we Gadget by
baking linjer compression so um we a
soon  It is Sword of the filter what den
Different from w eh
it is filters comes that end we learn It
From solving This Problem so we try to
find this as such that uh The It's
Energy is ehm Is exclos as possible to
the eh Energy that was Origin Lee in the
subwrit skills the small skills
and and since this is a linger map this
week the rest of the elastics so you can
you can learn this
and here you see that in stand of the
queen Stop That You So Before with Still
have a lot of detail  Right because It
was the real subwits  parable ehm Here We
Just get blocks Because We Only Its at
the same ehm Grid as dun uh Ashton
course Bridge solution
but Still the compressed eh variable
identify The Sharp gradunce
and of course we can Look at the Energy
and we see that learn compression
matches the small Skill Energy very
close So this is Indeed the training was
effective in the sensitivity epoxymated
Energy of the small skills Well Okay well
finally we come to the the real
Stuff
So What We Are Now going to do it May be
Something Special Because normally if
you look  at closure Models People
typically Look at the
Evolution Of You bar of the resolved
skills so It's Give It My app of you bar
pluss on close A model so we extende
system with the small Skill Dynamics de
compressed Most Skill Dynamic zo this
has the same Dimension as This one in
standdofiel Prime Which is typically of
much ehm eh Higher Dimension
we
ultimatically satisfied this condition
Right So if you multiply this and Tire
system by you bar s
transposting then The Inner product with
this part is identically going to be
Sera because these Things
Okay
This Is The Matrix k Which consist of 4
Parts so There to directional blocks and
then of blocks the diyakinal Block kan je
One is basically an Exchange of
informationer Energy between the result
skills de the blue one on the dijk no
Block is an extinct of information
Between The subwood skills And then The
Orange Ones are uh Energy Exchange
Between The large and the small skills
are this is what we Allah by taking a
model of this for
Zo dit is online go to say About It
Because The Actual  form of the game
So I'm going to show some results of How
This works
so Here We Do The cordirect de Vries
equation of course and We used Different
initial conditions For training and we
test nonsense just as conditions and how in
this case We Just Do redaction from 600
Points to 30 Points and we compare the
so That's A Factor of 20 we compared to
a Standard confusion On Little Net Worth
as a closure model
Zo ja de de solution solution in blue
The nice move solution That We sollby 4
what infect
Dutch for the cloudible followers
so solution really well and the
Standard eh  ehm convolutional now already
Network esclosure term eh yes it is
better that complete or
More interesting Maybe is the Look at
Energy that has here so The True
solution is again in blue That's The
reference solution Which is the Weekly
Line Here on the bottom it's not Energy
conserving eh Because The The
large skills Only are not concerting
Energy If You do on Take A closure
model you get The Purple Line And that
is of corsus Trade Line that costs Dead
doesn't have eh cloudible in it so It
will Still the Energy  preserving even
death That's Not what you want
Solutions
What is the olive interesting is to see
the sucrit cash zo This is Something
you would chipincally not Get Out Of A
normal eh closure model simulation
normal simulation what you do not have
Any Question for the subwood skills
Because you would On You Know ehm The
resolved skills that in this case Because
We have extended Our system with the
Creation for the subwit Energy ehm we
also get it so an in fact you see that
so this this Blue and this the
Orange Red ehm blocks this  show that uh
the reference
The reference subgrit Energy and the
excuse Metric solution are very much
comparisball so We Are actually solving
the right Thing
framework
also for this wait content
Okay so This is the Bit Of The intermediate
conclusion eh so He runs Now at two
items discotis First episode structure
enter
from his management It helps in settings
Ability and Alice is that already such a
chain left the training environ that
matches The Production experience we edit
this subwood Skill compression eh and eh
Maybe the most important Thing is that
we ehm we designed The
closure model such  that it is eh Energy
concerting and It's there for Stable at
design
Let's see there how much Time Do I have Okay
Okay
I will say a bit about this what about
training
about and Architecture What about
training European Models eh and so There
I Would say There to disting a proaches
That You Could Take One Is
griffithitting
soome You have some sickin All eh us and
function of time You Could say Okay I
have at Son of this thing Points I tried
to match the dirigitive so de
losfunction should look like this in Dead case
so um you  try to find the premators
of a new Matrix Touch That uh the 0
Network matches The rivitive ehm if you
have that then you can Marching time and
you can do productions So This is very
Common to do and relatively the easy
Because you can do this completeles
offline Right you generate your
training data And then you Pride to
match to 019 solution to the rivertive
you can also Do It projectory fitting as
record Ehm sometimes that populit and Bandit
Learning Different have the used for
this recolate project refitting because
it's table trying to Fit to the
Riverdale we try to Fit the Actual
projectory of the solvers Of The Last
function Is Now uh The reference
solution That We have for eksempel the
blue one and required to match Our
solution to eh
to this reference Solution
of course this solution you That We have
is a solution to Actual differential
equations Of The Lost function with
respect to the primitive
you need to know ehm The rivertive of
the solution with perfect to the new
Network premators So You have to
differentiate your complete  Audi
e-solver with  respect to you Network
problemators and that is much More
evolved That's much More difficult Thing
to do but it uh yes sorry interesting to
see How Dee chair methits eh compare and
eh not on in turn of aggression mean
his thumbs stability So this is what we
have Look that is a bit of the radical
eh
kind of avence by guiding we use and
one is this for the riverdive fitting We
Know actually that it Can Be In accurate
And unstable Because of some Old t-rems
from from  higher
eh from eh om zwitsalent eh already from
the nineties in this book deontoving
order and difference quation visious
culture fundamental lemma in eh in
Ordinary difference equations eh and
It's Not About New Orleans Networks but
it's easy to change theorem to Hold for
zero Network So if you have a nearl
Network that is Close To the matches
closedly The Time The rivertive then
some absylon and it has some lip
sheets eh condition then you get this
Arrow Down  And in the Book of hydra
this actually use That's  A Positive
Thing in the Sense at we have an
everbound but we actually Look for mit
Luka dit from the other side eh that is that it
if you have If You are ABC
Silent close with your hero Network you
can Still Be very far away from your
reference solution if you have a large
lip sheets constantly erm When Time
progressives so um yes effect that you
approximate your driving force well doesn't
Mean that you get a good odyse Edition
So this is a downside of the Riverdale
fitting and before that projectory fitting
The hope is  that you get Stable
results
wat ok you need to computer is the
Riverdale
with sensitive Legends
so One Option is discotited and
optimized one is optimized then discotis
So if you do the first one you need
differentible odds over
if you do the other One Thing you need
to solve set of a joint equation
Optima is de dik wante Just that your
Bridges please
and you get the correct Grace but if you
First optimized And then you discotage
you Sold The joint system then that My
be a Different time in the Creation
method not sure about  Heaven the
correct radiance
what  here in the discotage and optimize
system you need to have a differentible
not something that everyone has so and then
cervel issues design
choices that you need to make in the
tractory fitting approach for example
How many uh
timestamp do you used in your Lost
function My Looking forward as the
what's your projectory lengthens
there issues when you have stiffness in
your equations So if you use implicit
solvers Them backpropagation makes not
be so Easy and If youf coyotic Systems is
editional complexity erm and  erm yes There
Is Always the issue even exploding or
finishing Rangers Osso in this setting
so we have Tasty Question To investigate
The Different the Different proaches The
Witches
ski equation and this luxurious
case Yes
nuts doesn't really make  Sense to talk
about the
Wood Mean Square error Something like
that but we Use the socle Valet
Production time and Japan of Times to SS
The accury
and yes you don't have to make eh cervel Choice
so then you keep Dude optimized Them
discotized or discotison optimized so We
used Different Method for that uh That's
important but that the same time in
dozak details is that here sometimes Solutions
This is too solution that starts
initially very close and Day diverge
exponentially with you Expect for caotic
system and so this is Howard Looks  in
Space Time so I can better format ehm
Where is Solutions to dissie question
ehm and then we Look at the Case of
optimized them discotis Zo dit is one
one Option for projectory fitting and
receiver train on short projectories
that the soapalet prediction time
internals of leapon of time period is
larger Long projectories so hear the old
is color stuff is the Arrow so hear the
Arrow is a really Beaker
so we have a longer time for Which we
can do Good predictions If We have
Twenty on short projector is Them When
We Trend  on Long projectories Which is
Maybe  bitcounter into It
and eh If You compare so optimite and
discotized the griffithitting toilet It's
Only Better so
Maybe Not what we had hoped for
that If You Go to discotized ben op te
Maison this case The gradients are
correct that I said Before We Get quite
a bit Higher Valet Production Times so
special for depending have wit Again to
what projector re length is used to we
can go to brighter protection Times of
about 7 leapon of Times Kills
and
maybecraft to show comparis in this One
So Here we Look at the error as a
function of time for All The Different
massage 1 is Corsa odi Which means
There's No closure model then That's The
riverdifitting Wong
approach but you see It can be unstable
then There is the joint odi in Different
forms Which is the optimized den
discotized en There to differentible
solver Which is the discotized den
optimize en So This trentest sort of
Telling The Story This one gift The
overall best Performance
and uhm yes the de optimized in discordis
is much  More sensitive to the training
interval And Die comes  Less accurate for
for longit uh longer intervals erm
Yes, let's keeper that
This is the same but We All The Numbers
so My conclusions for today is the free
approve the three ingredients of the
talk so discotis First help you to
create Taylor Made close model It's a
use for framework When A division with nu
al Networks in your equations and it is
the analyzes
Pre serving structure improved
accuracy Because We add physics nowledge
and it Ultimate Possible to get lonniers
Ability  eh with using and the concept of
Energy conservation erm and then The 13
Ready Ent and bedt Learning by using
projectly fitting eh refund that discord
type then Optima is is the best credity to
use if you have a differentibles about
erm what the m-manchester
use for The Different strategy Star
typically difference
difficult to really compared Apples to
Apples
Oh yes this is the Bit of the software ball
so We like to your Julia because it's
really nice uh framework tooth yes
program differentable eh coach and too
Special  leaders this social package eh
in Which The differential equations.jl
eh  functional teaser avilable so we
built on to Dead and we Now Health was so
Our nephe stoke scouting Julia and We
are extending death with the difference
and Both forward as well so That's going to
be The Next Step to test the start data
show Today for the Simple One die
equations too then you have stokes erm and er
yes just inside advertisement we have
this Option to do and postdock erm oneer
post Rocket are instant to using this
Fellowship So if your Interested this then
Yes let me know and you can apply  using
that Yes this link ehm
Yes Thank you very much for your
attention and let me know There
questions
Talking
is there anyone
yourself
[Music]
so that before the training you I was about
about a training
how you actually
I'm wondering About
[Music]
Us Different hives of training You're
using matching your net And The tread
Tree
And Sound Can You
libraries
compared The Quest bittering Those Two
and also
decous this solution process requires
the training is so am in the inclusive
that training Cost I wondering you know
if you compared the costics  The High
reservations
versus
Still  the lord
keeper to train Daniel project to the
fitting The Because you don't have to
basically rindal
backwardsor Whatever Method you use
so The rifty fitting is keeper and what we
are trying is actually in the training
is to mix
your voice
[Music]
And then used that is the starting Point
for today fitting so then Yes you need
les eh work in the tractory fitting Part
Of Your eh solver but submit you are
Still doing that Method Right soul of
like a pre-conditioner like
prequelitioning with the  Riverdale
fitting When You Do It projectory
fitting so that that is that is One Way
and Which you can eat The Cost of the
tractory fitting
and Yes he had it Singers of yes Okay
what is the visional cost that is already there
Network eh compare budget solving the
equation
match Right Yes net of constantly valid
Question and I think for the current
wanderventional problems It is Maybe
better to just take a finer Mash but In
The End When We Go to Study of three The
Ey Believe It Was Play off
then stand boot went operator
comparison
to
the  settings Indeed ehm
Closer
with a course
wind
about because Yesdiepenzone Big you make
your little
I don't have a fool
Yes anime is not
for one thyle Need so many premators ehm
So this is quiet eh yes Lot of Trial and
Arrow testing
all the stuff you encounter with nu al
Networks This is silent eh ongoing I so
I think what we Try with this time of
approach is re make it last dependent on
the tip the exact Architecture orde
exact Hyper prematics at adding More
Knowledge edding more physics and I hope
that will also Surface Long  we go to
hide and enginess all right sun is good
okay eh
Lot of presents in that moment
harsh You are Raise your hand in Do you
wanna on meet yourself and ask I send
you have
Arch
I
don't Hear You
're not Yes yes
we do Something to Vision
for that
so wanting is that Solution
it later Times is much sensitive to
What happens
do the prementars of the girl Network
die Kools of the coyotic behavi of the
System so um you can an imagine that if
you have small Change In what kind
trampolinister condition payer
prematers that  that will have much
bigger effect because happened later doing
simulation The initially ehm so
This is the Reason Dead for Long
intervolves you get More issues also of
course the time integrator hit itself
typically accumulate errors so de The
Arrow of the timing the greater real
Osso be large at larger time in the
force so That's Another effect ehm and ehm
yes and the author thing I think is
that with ehm if you use optimize
denniscotis de de gradunce are not exa
ehm So detal Zoetermeer comes
model
Network  Closer model is I Would Taylor
made to the discotisation So if you
change your discotisation The you have to
retrain of course top top
University
to the juice but we didn't do that uh
or baby sometimes Sword of interpretability
but I see it Now that you have a code
that can solve your large Kill system
and Yes the penning on Which coach you
will train your little Network specific
to your code That's how I see it now and
Yes you have to clean yourself Yes That's The
fitty I Rather have smagherinsky model
runs I think Good  benefits on Heaven
something that this really matching your
discotisation and your code yes
Karin Ok
do you expecting extended
Yes I think
at it difficult to say so
December The Thing That I Show Today Is
A compression Still Of Maybe Yes Factor
of Tan to a 100 and there Think if you
want to go to have you stoke you want to
go for more and Maybe and Eats Direction
and yes um that that I'm not your eh If
that will scale end of course in love
you stokes eh the small skills are
really important in  the sensity Energy
doormin ehm dediteermin How your
Spectrum Looks Like and type My Beat it in
the test step we dit So Far that the
small skills are Still redan
tivoliant hè That's The Big difficult to
quantifi yet anyway extreme We Are
Looking now osoite the Energy Specter of
the tested we dit here the One det test
ehm but that something that I can
imagine that for Turbo
[Music]
on the result
Where are you now Collie couldas
actually eh have  some background in
divisionated  Creation of multi scale
Method and here came With A simular
Question and the I Still have to check it
so Yes I'm not sure uh I think kill the
Creation on multi skills Method you yes
you're looking for
Yes your looking for
function that you can integrate exactly
because on There some linger eh linger
functions And then Yes Joline rights Of
You cannot do that We Do Not make such
sanctions Here but I can Still imagine
that There are some links but I'm to be
Honest I can not full the answer that
question It will be cool  To Heaven Look
At that
awesome I know White 20
Easy experting version Okay erm
[Music]
Okay Question by Harris
Talk in the conser Virgin KDV equation
Standard CNN How does You comparefor The
busquets example
Oh okay yes
he would have to take our prepaid erm
this case Yes didn't show it Touch Right
erm I don't know buy Un top of my head
so The
well The prevention is not audio It is like
internal that er
the police That knew this hoes er do
simulations  The results and dinner check
for Burger
Oh yes  ice tea Maybe you can [ __ ] To Me
And then I can
[Music]
All right I
don't
past 5 minutes
for the wonderful Talking then you know
interesting
I'm surfing me ehm
also I hope that I'm with this Talk a
Future collaboration Campbell
in this
for the night
Okay we that Let's and I'm Let Me